well we're back at base camp Dave Eric
and I just had an awesome climatisation
rotation our first one we spent two
nights at camp one and two nights at
camp to advanced base camp a nice thing
is everybody felt great on this rotation
just spent the morning plotting and
scheming our next few weeks here well
that really means for us is to more
acclimatization rotations and then we'll
be set up for our samet bed totally
different ball game than any other
mountain I've ever been on two days ago
we left base to come up to camp to last
half hour so the wind's really
accelerated began to pick up we're in
the cook tent because our dining tent
got flat these guys are faring dinner
for us and even in this cook tent today
they went around fortified it with a
bunch of fixed-line try and keep this
thing up it was an exciting night I came
up from base camp to camp to yesterday
and I'm really happy to be here I'm
taking a rest day today and then
tomorrow I'll make my first trip up to
camp 3 which is where the climbing gets
very exciting for me above 23,000 feet
i'm going to start to see how i do
without oxygen and it becomes the real
test i'm really excited to just get a
little higher yesterday on this rotation
we made our first trip to camp 3 and
what that means is just to climb the
load see face to camp 3 sit there for a
few minutes and then we came down day
after tomorrow we plan to go up and
spend a night or two there as well
that's a 20 3,700 feet once this
rotation is over we'll descend a base
camp will rest for several days and we
should be then ready to go for the
summit just yesterday we have been to
seven thousand one hundred meters where
it is our chem three and then we have
almost drove the loss over there and
from tomorrow our work is to drop the
Lord's at South Col which is came for
and then which is the last came for
summit push I just like to say on the
friends everyone who knows us
you